I wanna do it finished this Monday
because it's going south oh it's Monday
night hi everyone a week off a weekend
off thank you so much for being patient
I was you were sick the PAC's plague
kind of caught up to me that's how what
I'm saying yeah here we are we had
already bumped it back a few days last
week for I think was also because of me
or something but then Friday I was like
I'm so sick when I back Monday your if
you're watching this merit well you have
already returned from Berlin or whether
you still be there on Saturday I will
still be there I'm actually gonna be
there for almost 10 days five trends
sarah glows under a bridge um twitch fun
twitch funds in Europe for the first
time this year
so Europe twitchcon consists of two days
in Berlin I am going to meet lots of
lovely streamers and have lots of fun
we're looking forward to it
and then I'm gonna stay five extra days
with my mommy in Berlin or on the way
back and quite Cleveland in Berlin she's
coming she's gonna come visit me
very good our friend Jake Decker it's
like his favorite city to visit
and I'm excited to just like do a bunch
of nothing like cafes and probably like
an art gallery but I don't really care
honestly like whatever I do is fine I
just want to spend some time with my mom
cuz yeah she's from Ohio and I live in
Oregon now so I don't get to see her
very much so this is exciting just to
just to spend time with family at this
point is pretty good I wanted to show
you some awesome yeah this is probably
some my favorite so far
alright I really I really love this one
this is a combination of inside jokes
from many of our previous playthroughs
okay tell me which ones all these are
from yeah so they left me in a creepy
more for days that's shocking shells in
the morgue from doesn't evil
Code Veronica yes right or no zere no
it's okay yeah no it might be zero no
there's no Morgan okay it's code for
Annika we write is that's from this game
I believe and the fire extinguisher is
Code Veronica of course was so bad on
the motivation poster maybe I'm
overanalyzing and thinking there's I get
inside Yoko there I think it's the
mountain one of those she has a support
group for all of our misfit characters
they wasted me um wrong enemy
yeah there's I could see Mikey sitting
there tubing like they kill me in every
game several times times well they like
we like Mikey like we love Mikey yeah
get so excited when we see him fire
extinguisher was like a white well like
the sweetheart from high school who we
never got to date I don't know I never
got the date anybody in high school
anyway um oh yeah so we have the senior
staff wristband I think I could be wrong
and that's happened a lot in this series
this season serious as well we might can
I combine it within the hour
yeah you have to so I mean your staff
member get out of my way that you can go
into the your skype that's giving free
yes talk to me yeah it's it's like
anytime you move the camera Claire's
looking really move Thank You frames a
second okay every time it like stops her
has just her blank face hmm
her so the recording looks good to me
but if it looks shitty to you that's not
a good sign no recording looks good and
I don't know but I don't like that your
voices blinken's
is it blinking a lot no yeah I mean it
looks pretty good to me now
okay so I've kind of funny up
machine-gun we're better against the
later boss so we that inside joke is
about the fact that we [ __ ] up and we
learned that flame rounds are meant to
be used on those plant men because then
they don't come back to life because
you're burning with pustules
I've just been popping them and then
they've been re growing and that's why
they've been such a pain in my ass yeah
mister died we talked about me a B and
Dan Reicher they played through it on
giantbomb we talked about this mm-hmm
it literally doesn't matter anymore and
like there's always the people in the
comments are like oh you're screwed for
the last boss fighting like ten bucks
that people said that for code Veronica
without the fire extinguisher like oh
look it was easy we'll be more than fine
we're not playing I'm like a hard
difficulty or anything I don't want to
bring that topic up after the last
couple weeks but what is so hard that we
need a cheat system no just easy mode
things I hate yeah whole conversation me
do with several people there are parts
of it that are worth having for sure and
like we whatever three bullets and this
submachine gun yeah but you have a lot
you can make some alright so tell me
what I should be doing do you remember
where I was I have this signal model
when can you actually open your map
because there's two spots and no you can
use that but I think you already did it
in both those spots I did it twice I can
tell you that you did in Lee's the NAP
room right yes
that's how I got the bracelet so you're
leaving the East area now you're going
back to that y shaped like Empire
Strikes Back room yeah go to the this
area the West
yes shaft let's go through north as we
called it back in college what about
this area at the greenhouse it's still
red what's left in there
Oh [ __ ] blue herb [ __ ] that I'm
not going back there
alright
add it to the list of forgotten items
age hey going back I'm not going
so wait nap room you did do that I swear
I did it because that's where I got the
third tier bracelet I feel so no the 13
bracelet was um oh no it was on the guy
who died from the plan right yeah the
guy who was squished against the glass
if you hear bumps every once in a while
GI Beom is like moving stuff around the
studio just so you know it's not me
farting I always assumed it's a fart
that's why I'm pointing out it's not Tom
Harting fine all right
no I what am I getting then let's let's
just go to the room just in case I'm
pretty sure cuz I killed a guy who came
out of the thingy yeah just go there
alright well do I need something no
you're not gonna run into anybody on the
way back that I know of there's a say
there's a save box back there anyway
all right where am I going then for the
right in here now the door no like Oh
where's wrong so into the Norden area on
yeah yeah that's skipping badly for me
um that scares me
alright continuing you're just sitting
10 min yeah are you going to the North
Area can I shoot any of these little
moth men
I'd be able to there's no point you're
no fun alright so to the main shaft oh
it's crazy this is what I meant like
Empire Strikes Back room just reminds me
of like Bespin um never seen it huh yes
you know what I haven't seen last Jedi
any Avengers film oh really
I don't care for it yeah I don't
I think it's blasphemy I get a little
nervous admitting it to like I think
you're you're in decent company it's
just like Oh care looks like a cultural
touchstone now for better or worse than
like I just always end up seeing them
and they're entertaining I suppose how
you doing kid
hey that'd be a little stupid idiot ha
ha nice blood she that's my new body
she doesn't look alive she's alive but
yeah Cheri um all right to the muff room
oh yeah her feet are moving a little bit
yeah I just feel like they run in slow
motion most of the time is this alright
yeah this is the right way I think nap
room yeah uh did you see that guy's ass
twitch I always see those guys asses
twitch hey there butthole touching I
don't like this
yeah I had to kill that guy okay maybe
there's another one in and that I did
this one muff yeah I remember that and I
did the other one there was two right
Osteria yeah I did both
you killed Wayne what do you want do you
want me to do the other one where is it
I think it's in the the area you're
going to anyway okay you definitely did
the other one the other one was the
thing that turned the power on in the
basement the other side
I wouldn't you so where am I going in
here back to their air strikes but no oh
right through that by sharing hope you
don't die huh you're gonna the door on
them right
uh the West yeah okay I assume I have to
just rotate this bad boy there's up now
is a button to you out there
we're like up these little stairs right
there I haven't done this very much I
know
I still don't think I understand
okay so have I ever been in here yet no
cuz that's what the the new bracelet
allowed you oh should I have like more
ammo there'll be a safe box oom you have
enough with your handgun for take it to
the next safe box I think this show more
when I don't know what's gonna happen
just the art of this series has just
been me becoming more selfish I actually
it never ceases to amaze me how little
you [ __ ] know about this series to
call yourself my guide yeah wait nice
well that is that I um I have a video
player somewhere what does that say
though operational nest wrecker what the
[ __ ] operation nest wrecker alright
Oh somebody opened this door with their
meaty arms oh it saved automatically
that's good don't act like I didn't see
that game I know shits about to go down
alright so there's a save box in here
but no say no do that code thing just
you can get rid of it there should be
the last one I think but won't it like
start a chain of events
it was turn the power on you're thinking
too much
OSs you got that do it first son oh
you're right I forgot
classic muff yeah I forget how to do
this
oh no go back one no I'll do the left
stick other right I like those puzzles
they're very like calming to me another
recent game had them I forget what it
was oh this has a red checkmark yeah
that's what I meant
now you just get rid of it no drop it
don't put in the box why you have so
many things you can get rid of that are
just crowding your box I like having a
crowd but I prefer just in case I prefer
it I'll put the tape in there too
no we all okay cool yes very cool what
[ __ ] do I need you could make some
machine-gun rounds I think you want it's
my least favorite gun it's good for boss
that boss though
okay so gunpowder is high-grade
gunpowder and gunpowder large would do
it Oh
high-grade gunpowder and a high-grade
gunpowder okay and then anything else um
that's not what I meant to do I have
bring the gun for large so you can get
more from those I think you can combine
those with the what large wait go to the
gunpowder large yet yeah
[Music]
no never mind um
[Music]
um I think you're good on health yeah
you're good on health look at all this
health I have yeah like I said I'm
taking one of these
yeah bran I for sure like that like I
said you're more than set we're being
very careful in this game um Amal why is
I still think you're fine um what
different you look like one flame around
left I only have one acid round in there
and then I think I have four here so
five acid rounds toad total I would just
stick to your handgun now if you need to
use a submachine gun then I would use it
sparingly but like I said that
submachine guns good against bosses okay
I'm just going you're gonna find more
we're not like to the boss yet it's a
little weird that I haven't gotten a
save room it ah [ __ ] this [ __ ] right
here this [ __ ] right here with a little
uh that's so dead space plate that space
never mind there's a you know the famous
seat no from dead space - yes I do
because I made a video on GameSpot
called the goriest scenes of all time
and I desensitize the [ __ ] out of myself
to like 50 different really [ __ ]
[ __ ] up gory scenes so that I could
make that video and one of them was the
dead space um uh I needle I need a
little scene it's so upsetting
also you just got a blue room so I saw
that we didn't forget it after all
I don't like this room you don't like
any room stop
oh no syringes nice that'll be I would
probably save that way yeah save regards
never mind that was my elbow I think no
it's the rain I just feel the wind in my
hair whatever happened to her
um who was that
Hilary Duff Hilary Duff she's still
around what's she doing now she's an
actor I think she kind of like does
acting stuff from time to time trying to
think of like the last big thing she's
been in but she ain't hurt and I feel
like she's doing fine she's that a flat
commercial that made that up
you're thinking of that guy who was the
parrot in Aladdin yato
he has so many good lines are we gonna
fight a guy again hmm
Oh William
oh okay Bob winders that's what I wanted
to say but I couldn't remember it's like
his famous line right it's a few yeah um
chest and abdomen G virus mutated
close relationship I wonder if that's
about the little girl
it's pretty [ __ ] up
do I need something that's the antidote
I accidentally started a cutscene here
that's good your dallying too much
anyway
careful careful careful
it looks like goldslick vodka cold
Schlick alright so should I just
immediately go back to Sherry cuz I did
not look in this room at all no not yet
[ __ ] shirt really yeah let me look
through this room yeah that's she's not
gonna die she's been alive this long
I wouldn't search the rest of the room
oh my god it's like two booths that's a
dick and a hand what's this one
ovaries you have you have no idea the
[ __ ] go like the redhead right Oh gross
what was that large large gunpowder sick
Oh a save room this place is a safe
space I was afraid but now I'm not
that's like a Bible quote I thought this
I was afraid but now I'm not
oh no it's amazing grace but now I'm not
[Laughter]
it's a Hilary Duff song my favorite
Hilary Duff song she's like oh good a
safe spot I was afraid but now I'm not
it was a classic she's a big present
evil person I guess I'm gonna save I
don't feel like I accomplished very much
but I don't want to do all this yeah two
hours Oh Hilary Duff made me loose no
way she plays Sharon Tate in the
haunting of Sharon Tate one of the was
the Manson Charles Manson's girls
killed her that was helter skelter right
yeah I believe but Sharon Tate they
already making a movie called Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood so this is in
addition this is like a totally separate
thing I assume because she ain't working
with Quentin Tarantino now it's the
haunting of Sharon Tate inside the crit
busy Hilary Duff movie that desecrate
the dead shits gonna happen it's
auto-saving mic sorry
it's auto-saving I knew it my god what
should i do what should I do
check his pulse
he looks so gross my son so dramatic
yup
I should have killed him on
so I know why because it was your
husband oh I mean who's to say why oh
let me turn it up I think I speak for
both of us when I say [ __ ] my daughter
Shari oh that [ __ ] is so dad but she
popped her with the stuff
I got this
[ __ ] tears
know what you're up against damn good
idea
trust me
what has she been I didn't realize that
would trigger it by walking back it's so
much a militia problem good oh god what
is going on in this room next me I'm not
ready for this
there's a lot of ammo lining around and
plus you got more than your jammies
shooters on your needle cartridges I
would have liked to use those see your
best he's throwing that [ __ ] me less
whining or fighting
[Music]
[ __ ] so much going on visually
what up you got us up what am i doing
I've shot the eyes yeah he's got another
one or I don't know just well I'm not
I'm not gonna you just got you yummy oh
there's one on his ass oh wait yeah we
pick that up
I go up in front of it QuickTime event
him really think [ __ ] is at this point I
don't know yeah go up to him yeah I
guess huh no yeah you do I think it's on
his front though
I [ __ ] couldn't do it
we can call this a test run
yeah he's what what is it
I think what do you kneel down II just
want to hose down Good Wife [ __ ] you I'm
not gonna give you satisfaction there
are more items lying around the
perimeter as well I got it
no you gotta shoot him when he's holding
that he drops it and stuck them that
sounds like it would have been super
helpful
his wife no this is on you
I'm gonna corner
he's so gross
yeah
I fight emotion yeah
okay you're literally almost out of ammo
I got it I got it
got what I got it stop sir ma'am
ah exactly think about how valuable the
Magnum would have been yeah you get it
right now
how do I throw this [ __ ] you just white
I'm gonna call this the Mike McCarty
attempt throw my bracelet Adam yeah my
way
there's probably ammo hidden around here
yes
just let them kill you for the love of
all yeah no I got it
this is a resonable five all over this
could be the last episode of oh I got it
I am the greatest warrior ever he saves
a lot of ammo in your state box yeah
there's stuff over there and I was
rooting for him service love all right
let me just double check for anymore
there was stuff everywhere wasn't there
yeah they really did not want you to
lose that fight that was nice of them
yeah you using the flame rounds on the
wrong tank do you mean I'm getting my
[ __ ] knife back thank you very much
Dan's everything and then you get my
opinion I am on a super low health so I
think even if I get like touched by a
zombie are you impressed with me yeah
sorry I was proud well oh well despite
my guide harming me actively no I was
yeah I was rooting you on the beginning
and then like you missed a lot of us and
movie shots and what it worked out
oh my god
what oh quit farting I don't know what
they're doing this wasn't the old night
this week we could record we could go
another night but this is it for me I go
to Germany tamari mm-hmm if sherry is
not healed I'm gonna be so pissed yeah
it's not the end game Oh what is that oh
Sh I play that tape okay all right let's
get a full heal up in this biz
let's get another full heal up in this
biz I need some ammo
maybe maybe what do you think I think
you're completely set on handgun well I
don't know
well first off combine all those the
Gunpowder yeah is that what you're
talking about
no no that herbs yeah I'll do that once
I'm done in the box what else do I need
you're you're not gonna have enough room
in the Box Frye stuff you needs or in
your inventory so and that's what I'm
saying combine the herbs to free up the
two slots cuz you need a lot right now
oh is this we're getting there
that nerve
what is that nerve and noise or was that
her I healed yeah so I have this lab
digital video cassette and then I have
all right what else do I need spark shot
Sparky old spark spark yeah I got my
knife look at these [ __ ] wooden
boards wait a minute did you that's body
still in the previous room who the guy
no I met the his his wife she went I
gave her the healing GU to go to Sherry
I said go to Sherry yes sorry okay I
almost like careful I know okay mm-hmm
that's why I don't a lot of stuff that
you know make it man
oh I don't want to end this with this
way you're right serenity now this
probably would have been more impactful
everyone I was making funny you buy one
of these guys does he eat it really fast
before they stop it
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] were you thinking
our orders were to free them in alive
you idiot you're gonna get two motive
alright we have a target resisted if we
had to take him on that's correct sir
Roger that let's move
let me tell me you shouldn't have
stopped recording there okay
turning off cam onward all right so what
else do I need I've just played the tape
so I can store that just in case um I
have a lot reload your magnums yeah you
can read let your Magnum so you just get
rid of those two extra bullets oh you
still have 17 of the high-powered rounds
what do you want me to do here did I
[ __ ] up oh no no no no no no okay sorry
for this gun you get switched between
high-powered rounds and regular Oh so I
need to switch it I need to switch no no
no don't switch you're already on Magnum
rounds I were just confused by the 17 I
saw those were the regular handguns just
disregard how do you know it's high
because you have 17 look you have 17
handgun rounds and the yellow magnum
rounds you're fine
goodnight launcher should I I'm out of a
member if you have another item box
before I like the big ending [ __ ] do I
need to uh do I need more submachine
ammo because I have no ammo for this gun
currently if you can make it yeah I
don't know if you can make it I don't
know if I can the two high grades I mean
you might as well use the rest of this
gunpowder
um I get those 15 high-powered rounds
for your Magnum right there and the
flame rounds the nine of them that you
have the people on you you mean sorry
oh okay there might be another item box
before the ending but I just don't want
to risk it again okay now I think that's
honestly good just leave room for other
stuff you might pick up well is there
really okay maybe maybe maybe actually
not you only have yeah get a first aid
spray you only have one or no I actually
better yet combine the green and blue or
if you have the health boost if you have
a red as well I don't have a red as well
oh never mind just bring the first thing
and you can take there's a few more
needle cards right there for your spark
shop you have an absurd amount of
aniline health thank you I don't we've
ever been in this bit of a business unit
I'm amazing where's the save oh right
there isn't one in here yeah great
it's alright it's a few bottoms you know
go back to the north area
sherry I'm coming baby
boy what if the main boss is sherry
that'd be so mean oh oh I forgot to turn
it down that would've been bad
we'll turn it back up now
my mom needs help
I met
sure
how are you know she looks like [ __ ]
[Music]
sure I'll be alright for a little while
yes she's three of the g-virus did you
hear that not look good well if you turn
into a zombie we have to lady
Oh super upper echelon clearance yes we
[ __ ] can
what does that mean but this facility
[Music]
sure sure is there's no time say bye
chicken
oh it's line let me go really quickly
she loved you okay you really get going
yeah
pick her the [ __ ] up
all right right about this jacket
we can look at all sorts of fashion
options but we're not in here
I'll buy you a pea coat the cheap one
cuz you'll grow out of it oh it's my
last item where I'm not ready uh you got
it sir for you engines and you're going
back to the empire strikes back room
okay
I don't have a bracelet it's the only
other thing lit up on the inventory
right
you're looking at all the dark boxes I
sure was to the main shaft sherry she
with me yeah
all right where am I going back elevator
oh thank fun
Oh
that's all look no-good such lies she's
saying your version of Sheree is from a
different part of a city she's just dumb
[Music]
um yeah you could I mean you're like
you're more than fine already but you
could no just keep going you're fine
you're not gonna have time to stop and
recover a knife anyway
hey should I get rid of anything am I
gonna get more stuff um yeah there's a
few thing you can get rid of you don't
wait go on
I don't need that's three extra spark
shots at the top you do need the
bracelet but why would I carry ahold
spark oh I see can you combine those at
the lever at the bottom actually I don't
know that yeah there you go um I think
you need that hand a knife if you have
you could either get rid of the knife or
the flashbang it is nice to have
now you're right actually you're
probably gonna see some tree people
anyway they come at me then I can defend
get rid of one of those first days I
think two is completely fine and that
should be good now just go there wait
did you say it lock and load sherry yeah
no did you I did before we did the box
Oh No yeah I'm getting all frisky what
is that no did I get on your flame
rounds you got nine of them here your oh
sherry you [ __ ] idiot
does she know how guns work honestly no
you don't need that I mean I'll just eat
it if I have to yeah no use it the first
thing you
I'm glad we had this flame rounds though
hey glad we have every amount of ammo we
could ever want for like another full
game at this
I remember somebody tweeting is it
called resident evil 2 because you only
ever have two bullets but I think that
person was just playing it badly
are you a lockpick or sherry yeah people
do that all the time on these
playthroughs they're like yo you're not
gonna have enough and then you easily
beat something like No
[Applause]
hurry up shake sherry thank you leaves
me in there welcome back for you that'd
be very Sunday good nice jacket
what is that yeah it's [ __ ] awful oh
you moving
no dawdling okay oh this doesn't look
good
[Music]
got a red herb right there and
everything I don't feel like there's any
time for a box should I use a box no you
don't need it actually [ __ ] now hold on
babbling gun um
okay wait actually yes yeah combine that
okay you know my mom greens you know you
can get rid of a knife because you're
not gonna see any other like Browdy
enemies how sure you well I mean just
trust me the knife is the least of your
concern right now um honestly I would
also get rid of that handgun at all you
have 20 magnum rounds 50 submachine gun
for flame your spark shot you don't need
that handgun rounds well okay what am I
done I just you don't need the rounds
the brace that I can't remember if you
need the bracelet now it's not not it
doesn't have a red checkmark on it oh
it's you know don't bring their handgun
rounds you don't need those
wait why'd you get rid of that first
night spray cuz I have two full heels
and you said I don't need more than two
full heels
hey you don't oh I see because you have
that's not a blue yeah cook oh um yeah
all right
and I can get rid of this flat
flash-grenade - if you really don't
think though you have at least one but
you definitely didn't need to
alright now what then okay worst-case
scenario we can drop something cuz
there's something coming up that I'm
trying to remember how many spaces it
takes up a yeah you're fine
alright so what am i doing
let's go shirt guy God where am I going
I'm gonna use this turntable I have a
turntable
yeah that's what I was thinking of is to
space there we go
she put some mini gun on her back like
it's nothing sweet
what is this I guess one of those
plastic katanas you get at the fair I
don't have a thing for this what is that
[Music]
just keep looking around what's going on
sweet just enough space I gotta put this
joint plug where where do you think I
mean she's this mini gun on her I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna be fine
oh wait
they made that door a little misleading
all right get ready the last boss battle
could be the end of Knievel for a bit
house I don't know
[Applause]
Leon Leon yeah oh yeah
whole place is coming down there's no
time to talk about this look you need to
get out fast
I know I found a way out I think I think
we can all make it where are you now
clear here still there Leon I'm sorry
you're breaking up
don't worry about me just get out of
here Leon Leon what else is still there
time time is like [ __ ] going
um don't worry bout your items just pull
the lever how that's right now you're
good just go on the train I guess
let me know try and let me on a tray
Jerry Jerry
all right hey what did I not kill I've
killed everything what
hi
[Music]
it's working No
[Music]
very first turned the volume down on
them you didn't turn it down I forgot
cuz I got so afraid but you're also not
even listening
which I guess is fair but yeah just the
spark shot gonna take too long for this
I would switch to the Magnum after this
and then the grenade launcher
you know Magnum so use the magnet now or
use the minigun right now just until
it's out how long is this fight cuz I
all have that many eels left
yes brother is back I'm gonna [ __ ]
die [ __ ] here Leon orange I mean he'll
but you're only on orange but that's my
last heal I know but you got a lot of
ammo just but just
is this hurting him
[ __ ] hey you know if I brought you down
to read it
no no so good I wouldn't say I'm great
you mind that's a blue heel too so you
have more than max health right now
there's not enough room I can't fit
you're fine
yeah you've got like you could use
Magnum right now I am I'm decided oh
where the [ __ ] is he
[Music]
[Applause]
but happening each other
[Applause]
he took a lot of damage she is
Mama's here
under Mandar hold on your dad oh right
I'm gonna turn it up but I'm gonna turn
it down I promise well
get out Thunder who is on the back of
that train
Sherri's on the horn
chuckling shovel faster Cherie
so what's the first thing you wonder
when we get out of here cheesecake
factory will be rude Claire
her mom Leon use anything so good to see
you
I told you we'd make it didn't I it's
cool it's cool he like got out at the
same time so you don't like worry what
happened to him yay that's it well
that's the first playthru the first
story
I was good yeah um did you say that you
liked this more than the original or do
you like the original better I have a
nostalgic but by today's standards
definitely I think the original game
when it first came out thank you or no
sorry first name when I first came out
was I think for its time pretty awesome
this is very good though yeah still one
of my favorite games this year which is
same something a lot of good games to
come out this year yeah I agree
um actually as of this recording I'm
probably playing Mortal Kombat now and
dazed on who I want to know about days
gone because I really like zombie games
a lot me too
and uh clips stories movies all of that
jazz I'm into all of it I heard such
mixed things about it some people I know
like hated some people I don't really
like it hmm
how you skips out of credits
yes do you want me to yeah
what does no way I killed him like eight
times it could be something else
yeah C's get degrees we did it 20 hours
but not this game is pretty long it is
long that's good wait yeah so we don't
know because there's talking within like
GameSpot like I think we're gonna move
to the gameplay channel because it's we
are crowding our youtube channel we
might also personally I think it works I
have a busy few weeks I'm up I don't
know when we'll start the B scenario I'm
really talked about it yeah I'm going to
Germany when I get back that's not for
like 10 days right so we're obviously
taking at least a week off I say we'll
probably take two weeks off to like
refresh it see what's going on and then
we'll start the next campaign feel free
to hit us up on Twitter because we do
listen to you guys for what you think we
should do next like should we do b-side
maybe we should try a new game maybe we
do like I don't know you spot about like
the days gone coming out or oh yeah you
play dead space or I don't play dead
later too but they're just as a heads up
sorry despite the week off last week
there might be a couple weeks off just
while we figure stuff out cuz GameSpot's
video team is in a lot of transitions
right now so we'll definitely be on the
game play channel I think which is I
don't want affect the knievel at all
it's just like it's a matter of like not
crowding our YouTube channels just do
something different we could always
livestream it instead yeah yeah time
different to be tough with that oh yeah
alright well we'll figure it out yeah
anyway as always thanks for joining us
to have the season everybody yeah
especially as we figured out a lot of
technical issues with a the cross
country recordings I know I'm pretty
good like it doesn't bother me too bad
at all thanks so much for the fan art
the new fan art seiji but also
there's a bunch of people I shouldn't
even started this mathy I believe it's
my Cathy I'm so sorry if it's like
different Nathan Shepard as always
thanks for keeping our stats up what is
it yeah we've had David in an art thank
you for your fan art as well Jonathan
Chi no nevermind
Jonathan chance it was saying thank you
to say he I'm one of them but anyway and
as and your if you're not in the discord
in Nathan Shepards comment which he is
kind enough to leave every single week
we the discord link is in there and
there's fan art and people just talking
even if we're when the show is not on
like people are just talking about
different horror games and it's kind of
become a community separate from the
show which is pretty cool also we talked
at PAX East but it was such a quick show
for me but like in the future at
conventions Mary and I were bringing up
the idea of doing like a meet-up if like
I don't know III or something if any of
you are in LA for e3 or anything maybe
it what I say Meetup
you know us well enough to know it's not
gonna be formal it's gonna be us in a
bar saying hi to people
I'd like yeah so yeah we could do it
around I don't want to do that but we
can there's a few things I'm shackled
looking soundboard oh yeah and you have
like a danger sign behind you as well
yeah I can't my my um I'm sterile anyway
thanks so much everybody we're doing
another season yeah berlin mary or i
will you're on in berlin yeah we'll be
back in a couple weeks we'll talk to
people on twitter yeah don't forget
there i'm a hearty looks like anime
hardy mary's marrakech mary spelled like
merry christmas and yeah thanks
everybody and we'll see you i don't know
when but we'll see yeah I'll see ya and
we like yeah goodbye adios adios I can't
believe I got a C rating it's pretty
good it's ok I got I got an A+